COLT MCANLIS: Hello everyone.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
COLT MCANLIS: Hello.
Are we all properly boozed?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
COLT MCANLIS: Are we
all properly boozed?
AUDIENCE: Yes!
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
My name is Colt McAnlis.
And I know I've gotten a lot of
weird confused emails and looks
in the past couple of
days about like what
is this Perf like
a Pirate thing?
And so for those of you
who don't know what it is,
I want to give you a
little bit of history.
So last year, we did this perf
matters meet up on SFHTML5.
And it just randomly happened
to just weirdly land on Talk
Like a Pirate Day.
And so I said, you know,
hey, how many times do you
get a chance to be
fired in your career?
And so I'm going to do
the entire talk in pirate.
So historically though, this
was a really we're anomale.
Because after that,
that happened.
For those of you on the live
stream, like autocomplete.
No one cares about my Twitter
or my blog, Colt McAnlis pirate.
Which I thought was great.
But more importantly to me,
like apparently this talk
changed someone's life, right?
Like "one minute in, and by far
the best talk I've ever seen."
I have no idea how to
help this man any further.
First off, how do
you top that, right?
This man's life was changed
because of my crazy pirate
talk.
Which is a little
awkward for me tonight.
I mean here you
all are, pirated,
and our cast our
crew is pirated.
And it's a little
awkward for me just
come up here and start
talking like a pirate, right?
AUDIENCE: No.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
Keep that enthusiasm.
So what we're
going to do tonight
to make sure that everybody
wants to talk like a pirate is
we're going to sing
a little pirate song.
Together.
AUDIENCE: Argh!
COLT MCANLIS: Argh.
So I'm going to headstart here.
I want to invite all
the speakers, everybody.
I guess I'm keeping the mic?
So now everybody, if you want us
to talk like a pirate tonight,
we need to hear you
sing, louder than us.
Watch the words we're
going to have here, OK?
And make sure that
you sing along.
This is going to be available
for download afterwards,
by the way.
I want to hear some ringtones
on the streets of San Francisco.
[PIRATE MUSIC PLAYING]
There's a break.
Got to wait, see.
You got it that time.
All right, ready?
Here we go.
[PIRATE MUSIC PLAYING]
Let me hear you!
Louder!
[PIRATE MUSIC PLAYING]
Keep going now!
Here we go!
[PIRATE MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
Now get off me stage,
you minus doubloons!
Let's get to what you
all came here for, aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye.
COLT MCANLIS: I said aye!
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: Listen
here, you rascals.
I didn't come here to hear
you bellow to your mothers.
I said aye!
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: That's
what we be hearing.
My name be Captain Mainroach.
And I'm here
tonight to teach you
how to keep your vessels running
smooth, and fast, and straight,
and through, through the
world of performance.
I think I swallowed a bug.
Just give me a second.
Grog.
Tonight we be here for one
thing, lads and lasses.
I be here to teach you how to
properly plunder that battery
booty.
Arr?
In order to understand
that, we need
to talk about your mobile ship.
Yar she be a good vessel,
out about your day,
helping you haul your
load, fight your battles,
and upload pictures of
various parts of your anatomy
to the internet every day.
It's a-- I'm on Snapchat.
I see what goes on.
And really most of you
shouldn't be on it.
Except Peter, he's OK.
He's a good looking
man over there.
But everyone know that the crew
be the life of your ship, aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: I said the crew be
the battery of your ship, aye?
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: That's right.
But the fact is that you
be going about your day,
plundering and pirating,
your crew is going to die.
Yeah, it's true, it's true.
The pirate's life
is hard with scurvy,
and the scorn of the sea,
and checking your email
15 times a day.
They just die.
Arr, the cracking.
Yes.
That's a different metaphor.
We'll get to that one later.
But I like where you're going.
So the question be, the more
you plunder, the more you do,
the more your crew
dies, and the more you
need to get back to
port to get somewhere
to throw the dead
ones overboard and get
the nice live crew with
a real pulse, right?
Yar many a time we all be
cast to sea with our energy
crew thrown-- are we
getting the metaphors?
Our energy crew be
thrown overboard,
trying to find a charge
until we get back home.
And the fine traders at
Purdue Pirate University--
go Fightin' Boilermakers-- did
a study of the top pirate ships
out in the sea.
And what they found was that
these cockroaches of captains
had no care for how their
crew was being slain.
They were letting the
entrails of their men
just be flaunted all over
the floorboards where
the gulls come and nest and
feed upon their entrails.
For the standard
pirate activities
of tossing birds and
reporting the news, only 30%
of their slain crew actually
went to the pirate deeds
that they be doing.
The other 70% of their
crew that they be slaying
was gone to things like checking
whether there was an update
or figuring out whether or
not they can upload user data
or downloading
advertisements to display.
And the truth is
these captains had
no idea what was eating
up all of their crew.
It was as though there
were a magical shark, just
hiding aboard on their deck,
waiting to eat their crew
when they weren't
looking around.
Land shark.
Ship shark.
AUDIENCE: Narwhal.
COLT MCANLIS: Narwhal?
AUDIENCE: Battery shark.
COLT MCANLIS: Battery shark.
I like the crew tonight.
Yar!
AUDIENCE: Yar!
COLT MCANLIS: When we
get this much feedback,
it means the grog was good, aye?
Aye.
I'm seeing the back rows
are not grogging enough.
All right, the front,
quiet down for a second.
I just want to hear the back.
Aye!
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: Now the front.
Aye!
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: I'm going to give
you one more chance in the back
there.
And then you go out, and
everybody else comes in.
One more chance in the back.
Aye!
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: All right.
AUDIENCE: Front!
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
Front!
AUDIENCE: Aye!
COLT MCANLIS: That's good.
He caught you off
guard with the timing.
Anyhow, back to--
I had a point here.
I was getting to it.
There was a shark, and
it was eating your crew
when you weren't
paying attention.
This is a really
important metaphor.
I'll come back to
it in a minute.
But the truth is that
captains and users,
and though they be paying
you and your pirates to go
about your day plundering, and
pillaging, and bringing back
the spoils of your
activities to them,
be understanding
that captains who
don't manage their
crew-slaying battery habits
are not good stewards to
be part of their fleet.
And they be using
applications like Carrot
to identify bad applications
that be slaying crew
and using their battery unjustly
so that you can uninstall it
during the day and get rid of it
from killing more of your crew,
like the shark.
See?
It was an important point,
and I came back to it.
That's called going
back to a point.
I took a pirate-speaking course.
It helped me, I think, clarify
my methods since last year.
I got a lot of confused
emails from people
about what the
kraken was and why
I went into such
graphic detail about how
the pirates were slain.
Also, some groups that were,
on behalf of pirates, let me--
Anyhow.
Hashtag perf like a pirate.
So the question be,
how long can you
be at sea plundering before
all your crew be dead?
Let's look at a
fully stocked Nexus 5
vessel from the queen's fleet.
Aye.
She be a pretty lass, although
covered with barnacles.
The queen, I mean, not the boat.
[LAUGHS] Aye.
Onto the planks with you.
A fully stocked
Nexus 5 vessel can
remain out at sea
for one month a time
before your crew
get bored and start
eating each other for fun.
Mmm.
We've all been there.
But as you go through your
day, the more active things
ye be doing when you're
not in standby mode,
plundering along the shoreline
of cellular, and Wi-Fi,
and wake lock, and screen,
can leave you stranded
in the middle of the
ocean without any crew
and just birds to
pick at your school.
Not a good place to be.
Sometimes, you see
these ads online
for like, free skull
pecking by a bird.
Don't click on them.
They're just money traps.
Because you're like,
you talk to them,
and you're like, of
course, we should go out.
This would be great time.
We could take the kids with us.
But then you never use it.
Oh.
Apparently, that one
was a little too far.
So every pirate captain
knows the golden rule,
and that be that one
second of active pirating
and plundering be worth two
minutes of standby time out
in the ocean.
This is a very important
metric for ye captains.
This way, you can line up the
crew members you like least
and have them killed first.
[LAUGHS] Arr!
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: I
found someone asleep.
And so then, the
question we have,
if we're doing 50 acts of
piracy for one second each
in a single hour, that's equal
to 100 minutes of standby time.
Now, with these numbers,
it's pretty easy
to see how fast your
crew can be slain,
leaving you adrift
in the wide open sea.
It's math.
We be pirates.
I understand.
But we should still
be able to do this.
And if you can't do that math,
then what's going to happen
is the users and the people
financing your voyages are soon
going to realize
that you may not
be a good steward of
your ship, and they'll
stop financing and giving you--
AUDIENCE: Walk the plank!
COLT MCANLIS:
Trying to figure out
if that's coming from up here.
No?
It's the shark.
Yar.
This is what we
call live internet.
Someone's probably calling me
from the internet right now.
Like, he's on TV!
TV.
Anyhow, the point be that unless
you be getting your battery
handling under control, you're
going to end up with a ghost
ship out in the sea
with no one to finance
your plundering
or your pirating.
They won't be given you
any gold, any booty,
or any rum, which as
we all know is not
why we're in this business.
So Captain Mainroach here be
with three tales of pirate woe.
Any man who does not
listen to these three tales
is set adrift on his own course.
And I take no recourse
for his action.
If you not be listening
to what I be saying today,
woe be you in Davy
Jones's locker.
First, we'll be talking about
the ship the S.S. Wakelock.
Yar, it be a good vessel but
had a naive captain running it.
Very insecure he was
about his pirates, indeed.
And he would wake up the crew
at very inopportune times
during the day and night
to do trivial things
like count the number of
cannon balls, or swab the deck,
or just look at the sky
and admire it together.
We are pirates.
We still have hearts.
The sunset is good.
But the naive
captain had one flaw.
He woke up one day
in a mad frenzy
and couldn't control himself and
kept the pirate crew awake for
so long that they started
dropping over dead.
They just fell, and fell,
and fell from exhaustion.
He had depleted all
of his resources
simply because he
couldn't contain himself
and didn't let them
go back to sleep.
And what happened was the
ship was sunk and eaten
by a giant sea turtle.
So are we all clear
on the metaphor here?
OK, so really
quick, what this is,
I'm talking about battery-- No.
Once you say sea turtle,
you can't go back.
So let us be learning from
the ship of the S.S. Wakelock.
First off, there
be tasks that ye
need to be doing in
the middle of sea.
But there are other
tasks which you
can wait until you are plugged
in back to port to be doing,
for example, downloading
updates to your applications
or maybe doing some high compute
intensive task of moving cannon
balls from one side of
your ship to the other.
You don't need to be
doing these out at sea
while your users are
trying to figure out
if you're a worthwhile
investment for their careers.
Arr!
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: I'm the captain.
I can say that.
Also, you need to
make sure that you
don't be waking your crew up
using a wakelock methodology.
You want to be
moving to something
like a hierarchical
system of using an alarm
manager to handle it.
Did everyone get it here?
It's a lock making wake.
It's a nautical pun.
See?
It's a lock, and
it's a wake lock.
Laugh harder.
Arr!
AUDIENCE: Arr.
COLT MCANLIS: I didn't write it.
I'm sorry.
This is my favorite
part of the whole--
it's a lock making wake.
I don't think you understand
how hard I worked on that.
That was like a whole day.
I just chuckled to myself
like, no, it's a lock.
They sink normally,
and it's making wake.
[MAN LAUGHING]
This man, someone
get him a t-shirt.
And more rum.
AUDIENCE: Yar!
COLT MCANLIS: Yar!
Now, let's talk
about the S.S. HTTPS.
Apparently, we know
about this ship.
It was run by a vile
captain, the Duke of HTTPS,
who had a love on the
mainland named servlet.
And he loved to spend all
of his time communicating
with the fair lass
that he wanted to wed.
But when he was out at sea,
he couldn't do that easily.
So he had to find a way
to transfer his message
packets back to her in
an efficient manner.
But the only thing
he could come up with
were vile demon birds that
used the blood of his crew
to initiate their
transfer protocol.
What is that noise?
I'm going to ignore
it and keep going.
This is an important point.
I don't want to touch anything.
Is someone Instagramming me?
I told you to put that away.
Anyhow, these
birds out here, how
they work-- describing birds
now because this thing-- so
the vile birds used one simple
methodology to fly around.
He would have to slit the
throat of one of his crew
to wake the bird
from its slumber
before it could
make its mission.
And then, he would
have to keep killing
the crew at regular intervals
after the bird took flight
in case he needed to find his
way back with the messages.
Everyone getting the metaphor?
We'll talk about
that in a minute.
So one Christmas morning,
the Duke of HTTPS
decided to send many messages
of love, and lust, and promises
of smooching to his
crew-- or not to his crew,
to his servlet.
[LAUGHTER]
I guess the bird wouldn't
have to actually fly that far.
So wait, if he were
sending those to his crew,
why would he be
slaughtering them?
AUDIENCE: One too many.
COLT MCANLIS: One too many?
OK, let's back it up.
Let's back it up.
He's talking to
servlets on the mainland
using the birds
that eat his crew.
We're going to get
this back in line
now with the binging
and everything else.
We can recover.
We can recover from this.
Yar!
AUDIENCE: We're drunk!
COLT MCANLIS: I
pulled something.
So these vile birds would then
slaughter his crew and return
with messages.
But on this Christmas Day,
he spent so much times
sending messages to his
lovely servlet on the mainland
that he ended up
slaughtering all of his crew
before he realized it.
Now, those same demon
birds run his ship,
and it's captained by the
ruthless Captain Featherbeak.
I hate this bird.
It pecked at my head for
way too long one day.
Remember that head pecking
vacation I talked about?
This is the guy.
Just don't click on it.
OK, moving on.
So let us learn
from the mistakes
of Captain Duke of HTTPS.
First off, know
what kind of bird
you be using for what kind
of transfer you be using.
You don't need to be sending
out packets when you only
have a 2G bird available.
Why?
Because a 2G bird
requires the death
of more crew members to
effectively communicate back
with the mainland.
If you can batch your
messages and wait
until you may be closer
to use a Wi-Fi bird,
this is going to slaughter
less of your crew.
Wi-Fi bird, nocturnalis
erapis is the--
AUDIENCE: Lazy load.
COLT MCANLIS: Lazy
load, yes, that's
the name, the scientific
Wi-Fi bird name.
In addition to
that, you shouldn't
be doing the rookie mistake
of every pirate captain
and sending your
birds to mainland,
waiting to see whether or
not they respond to you.
No, you should be using the
tried and true technique
of bartering with the
commissioner of that fair town,
and have them send you data
when things have changed.
Such a barter is often known as
Google Cloud Messaging system.
Yes, this way, you
slaughter less of your crew.
And they send the birds to you,
and they slaughter their crew.
This is actually a very
highly important technique
to keeping your ship crew alive.
Hashtag perf matters.
Yar.
Are we getting all the
metaphors at this point?
Now, when you're
out in the ocean,
it's important to know what
kind of resolution you be using.
And sometimes, you be sending
the birds up ahead of you
to be looking
around and charting
the area for where you are.
Now, it's important to know that
the higher you send the bird,
the less energy it uses.
It's a thermal updraft system.
So you need to make
sure that you're
using the right resolution
bird to get your GPS.
I worked on this one a
little too hard, I think.
The main thing is
if you don't need
to be using a bird that
gives you one meter accuracy,
you should wait to be using a
bird that gives you two mile
accuracy or what we
call network GPS, yar?
Familiar with network
GPS, hands up.
Yar, also triangles.
Familiar with
triangles, hands up!
For those of you who
didn't raise your hands,
let's try that again.
We're talking about a triangle.
Do you know what a triangle is?
Still some hands that are
really unsure if they'd
like to participate in
tonight's activities.
Does the fact that everyone's
wearing a pirate hats--
you're in on this.
You either raise your hand,
or I'm going to keep talking.
Do you know triangles?
Yar!
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
COLT MCANLIS: One
of them in the back
was like-- he wanted
to check first
if everyone else
was going to admit
to having triangles
in their repertoire.
He's like, oh, yes, and
me-- oh, no, I mean,
no, I don't know
anything about triangles.
I'm not that guy.
Please don't contact me
for job opportunities.
Yar.
You all be a strange crew.
Also importantly, when
you let your crew sleep,
make sure you bring
your birds back in.
Don't keep your GPS awake when
your application be sleeping.
Because otherwise,
your birds will land.
There will be no crew on deck.
And they'll just start
eating anything and anyone
they want while ye be sleeping.
This is actually a
large, large problem
with application
performance, just
eating all of your crew members
while you're actually asleep,
because they can't
defend themselves, right?
Because they're asleep, and
it's a bird, and it's evil,
and it teleports, and sometimes
it wakes up in the night just
staring at me.
But we're not here to talk
about my problems anymore.
Hastag perf like a pirate, yar!
AUDIENCE: Yar!
COLT MCANLIS: Now I got one
final story for you tonight.
It's more of a song, really.
Well, not a song.
We already did that.
I want to tell you the
story of Captain Lubberz.
It's very small.
You didn't see it.
Captain Lubberz
was a mad captain.
His ship had to be bright.
So he set his crew aflame
to create the light.
But when his crew were
through, he lit the ship, too.
Something, something
light-- yes.
I'm a pirate, not a poet.
Get over it.
I was supposed to click
while that happened.
Let me try that again.
So there was a mad captain.
He wanted his ship to be bright.
He set his crew on fire
to create the light.
And then, it burned
down because he really
didn't have a fire
extinguisher back then.
And how did they set fire?
Never mind.
And the truth be
that the brightness
of your mobile vessel does
have a direct correlation
to how many crew be slain.
The brighter your
vessel, the more skulls
packed upon my graph here.
Yar?
But the problem is as a
captain application developer,
you really don't
have too much control
over the brightness of the
OLED ship manufacturing, right?
Although some of the
very smart captains out
there are realizing that
they do have some control,
and this is worthwhile to the
users of their applications.
The thing you need to learn here
is if you don't have to burn
your crew, don't.
Or if you can, only burn
the left half of your crew,
like my grandma used to do.
Bless her zombie bones.
There's some
applications out there
who understand that
they can modify
the brightness of their
pixels on their screen
to use less battery life, which
is very important for smaller
devices which may not
have larger crews.
This is still a very
large problem today
with some form factor
ships out there.
AUDIENCE: Once you go
black, you don't go back.
COLT MCANLIS: Uh, uh, moving on.
I want to tell you something
about one of our fine pirate
captains that'll also
be speaking today.
It's pirate Ilya Grigorik.
Everyone say it, Ilya Grigorik.
When he comes up, you have to
say it that way, "Grigaarrik."
When it starts to hurt, that's
when you know you hit the right
number of R's.
Captain Ilya has a
fantastic saying that we all
try to live by here on
Perf like a Pirate Day,
and that's you can optimize
what you can measure.
And most of the time, when
your crew be slaughtering,
you need to know what's causing
it so you can effectively
go in and fix the problem.
Now, there's a fantastic
plug-in to your ship.
Well, specifically from
Qualcomm's class vessels
into the Eclipse
floorboards, that
allows you to monitor how
your crew be getting slain.
This is a fine
tool called TERPN,
and you can find it at
the lower link there.
It's really important
how these tools work.
Effectively, they
allow you to see
how standard parts
of your mobile device
be eating up battery
so that you can find
a correlation about how the
network radio may be on,
and the vultures
may be buzzering,
and how that may be
actually slaying your crew.
This will allow you
to then pinpoint
what parts of your
application ship
stack you can then go in,
and find, and optimize.
We all got that?
Fantastic.
They're giving me the time.
The other one is a fine tool
from the new Android tool suite
called Battery Historian.
It actually gives you a
lot more counter power
than TREPN does
and it actually has
new counters for the
Android L release
to get even more information
about battery performance
on your mobile device.
Arr!
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: I had to
say that because someone
checked his watch.
Arr!
AUDIENCE: Arr!
COLT MCANLIS: That be it
for me, lads and lasses.
Thank you for listening to me.
Remember, perf
like a pirate, yar!
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Did you swap out?
MALE SPEAKER 2: I got it.
MALE SPEAKER 3:
Great presentation.
MALE SPEAKER 4: I'm just
getting my computer.
MALE SPEAKER 5: What
type of watch is that?
COLT MCANLIS: It's
just a [INAUDIBLE].
I'll take your flash.